so what do you do I play chess so do I I
mean what do you do for a living I play
chess for a living but you can't play
chess for a living unless you're
vishwanathan
[Music]
but actually you spend also a lot of
time after this Beast removed did you
try really to calculate all these
complications all these variations till
the end somehow and this was it possible
no I was thinking what to eat tonight
I'm coming home
[Music]
after this loss have you are you
considering leaving chesan no
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
so wait you don't want me to sing what
about dancing
[Music]
still wondering if Mr Anand could
elaborate what he means by
doing your best again be doing you doing
your best means doing your best I don't
know why you don't understand English
[Music]
I mean hang on guys today was nothing
today was not the chess of people who
just know how the pieces move oh yeah
yeah today was very strong sorry
so this you guys obviously uh
uh secret uh
I mean you practice a lot I mean I don't
really want to see how you play cricket
either if this is the way you play chess
but as they say even a donkey won't hit
the same Stone twice in this match uh
when Doppler started doing all the stuff
then I felt
much better and this time I mean there
was nothing really to protest you can't
protest that the opponent isn't talking
to you but I
uh then we look like lovers but I'm
like
[Music]
he's under four minutes now he's crazy
Madness come on this is unbelievable
this is shocking I'm stunned to see it
he's thinking this long on this the
fourth move of the chess game analyzing
what I do not know but smearing has
successfully thrown him off and now he's
used a minute and 30 seconds to think
about four moves this is completely
ridiculous he's putting himself into a
deep deep hole
[Applause]
and look at him make a minute look like
a year he's ripped another point off the
board
[Music]